[Applaus]
es ist soweit ach du
scheiße die Karre ist da ich habe mir
meinen größten Traum erfüllt und einen
510 PS starken Porsche 91 GT3 gekauft
das Problem der Wagen hatte einen Unfall
und ist nicht fahbereich wir fangen
heute damit an den Wagen auseinander zu
nehmen um zu schauen was alles kaputt
ist und mit der Reparatur zu beginnen
welche Schäden uns alle unter der
Verkleidung erwarten finden wir heute
schmerzhaft gemeinsam heraus war
ja
ich will dir einmal sagen dass ich
unglaublich happy bin wie gut die erste
Folge und das Projekt bei euch ankam wir
Rackern uns seit Jahren den Arsch ab um
möglichst guten high quality content zu
produzieren und uns immer wieder neu zu
erfinden die beste Möglichkeit all das
zu supporten ist das Video zu liken zu
kommentieren und den Kanal zu abonnieren
das gilt nicht nur für dieses Video
sondern für alles was noch kommen mag
und für jeden anderen Youtuber auch also
vielen Dank an jeden einzelnen der das
tut und uns dabei hilft weiter kostenlos
den bestmöglichen Content zu produzieren
vielen Dank bevor wir mit dem wier auf
Aufbau der Karre beginnen können müssen
wir uns erstmal eine Werkstatt
einrichten und freundlicherweise hat
twinbush nicht eins nicht zwei sondern
drei oder vier Pakete rumgeschickt und
uns mit allem ausgestattet was wir
brauchen und dann steht im Wiederaufbau
meines 992 gt3s nichts mehr im
Weg mein erster eigener
[Musik]
Werkzeugwagen
ach du
scheiße riesig das ist der größte
Kompressor den ich jemals in meinem
Leben gesehen habe jeder der jetzt in
der Industrie arbeitet wird sagen ist be
weit nicht der größte es ist der größte
Kompressor den ich jemals gesehen habe
das ist ja komplett
ge willkommen in meiner neuen
Werkstatt krank aber eine ne Werkstatt
erfüllt nur ihren Zweck wenn wir auch
ein Werkstück haben aber die Karre steht
draußen die soll aber natürlich nicht
draußen stehen Auto muss rein das ist
der verzweifelte Versuch 1400 kg
leichtes Auto erst wenige Zentimeter in
die Garage und dann noch mal wenige
Zentimeter auf die Hebebühne zu schieben
aber all das hat sich schwieriger
gestaltet als gedacht unsere
Heckstoßstange ist eh kaputt wir
benutzen das hier als bounmaterial und
schieben mit dem Lieferwagen
jetztuf
[Musik]
und im Prinzip ist das hier jetzt der
echte Start des Wiederaufbaus die Karre
ist oben wir haben eine Bude gefunden in
der wir die Karre wieder herrichten wir
haben eine hebbebühne besorgt wir haben
das Auto besorgt wir haben Werkzeug ich
habe Robin an meiner Seite den
Wiederaufbau steht jetzt nichts mehr im
Weg
krank h alles so scheiße an hier hört
man die Tür da hört man so die
Glassplitter die ganze Zeit
drin da hat man gehört das Gutachten
dass wir bekommen haben hat gesagt die
wieder Instandsetzung kostet 180 000 €
aber wir glauben dass wir es wieder
hinbekommen easy fix wir hten das Auto
nie auf eine hebbebühne wir hten nie die
Räder ab wir haben uns nie die
Aufhängung wirklich angucken können
Lenker verbogen das Auto ist nie gerollt
wirklich Gefahren schleift irgendwo was
Lager kaputt dur schön Aufprall ja eine
oder andere Sache wird auf jeden Fall
noch gut
reinschalen
gut ja jeder einzelne Schaden ist
richtig scheiße für mich und für meinen
Geldbeutel positiv daran ist aber dass
ich bei autodog und unzähligen weiteren
onlineeshops richtig Kohle sparen kann
und das über save it meine eigene App
und genau das könnt ihr auch tun ladet
euch also über den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung jetzt saveet herunter
wäht den Creator Code Dave aus und fangt
an in unzähligigen onlinehops bei
Bestellung bares Geld zu sparen völlig
egal ob Nike Volt about you Lieferando
Decathlon und unzählige weitere gerade
jetzt wo es zur Weihnachtszeit geht und
ihr viele Geschenke für Freunde und
Familie kauft könnt ihr da richtig Kohle
sparen also ladet euch die App jetzt
runter unterstützt mich und spart
richtig Kohle beim onlinees
shppen also als erstes Felgen runter das
wird jetzt schon mal ein Spektakel 600
newonm Drehmoment Centerlock wheels wir
geben unser Bestes was man dazu wissen
muss Robin arbeitet bei Porsche arbeitet
also den ganzen Tag an solchen Karren
das ist mega geil ich kann es vernünftig
lernen kriegt vernünftige Informationen
ihr auch und wir bauen die Karre so
wieder auf wie es sein soll nach
Vorschrift bzw so wie es von Porsche
gedacht ist am Ende ist das eine
rennsportwaffe diese Karre und es bringt
nichts da irgendwie dran rum zu freckeln
und mit Halbwissen irgendwie Sachen hin
und wieder abzubauen da muss ein
geschultes Auge mit dabei sein muss das
machen und da bin ich mega happy Robin
an der Seite zu haben lang ich muss noch
mehr mehr Bremse mehr
[Musik]
Bremse okay
so schaut's dann
aus ein Schaden mehr als gedacht eine
weitere Felge
gefreckt Bestandsaufnahme Schäden 992
GT3 unfallprojekt wir wissen Aquaplaning
Schaden der ist irgendwie vorne hat er
ein Hit bekommen und hat sich gedreht
und ist überall einmal gegen besonders
vorne Fahrerseite und hinten vorne ist
die Frontschürze kaputt der Lufteinlass
hier drunter die Schürz also basically
ist vorne alles was relativ weit unten
am Wagen ist kaputt alles was ein
Stückchen weiter oben ist
glücklicherweise nicht und nur wenige
Karosserieteile bedeutet unsere
Sichtcarbon Motorhaube und das
Carbondach sind in gutem Zustand was
mega mega gut ist ansonsten hier vorne
Frontschürze das muss alles gemacht
werden glücklicherweise die Lampen beide
ganz so kleine Teile wie der Blinker die
wurden erwischt hier an der Seite geht's
weiter glücklicherweise hier dieses
ganze kotflügelteil ganz der Spiegel hat
unten irgendwie ein Hit bekommen oder
ist vielleicht sogar hier komplett in
die Scheibe rein weil die ist nämlich
kaputt die Tür ist Fritte also Tür
Scheibe und hier unten der Schweller hat
auch ein Hit bekommen wurde
freundlicherweise schon von dem anderen
Porsche Zentrum wo das Gutachten gemacht
wurde aufgeschnitten drunter gibt's
keinen Rahmenschaden innen drin hat
durch diesen Seitenaufprall der
Sitzairbag der dachairbag und auf der
anderen Seite auch der Airbag ausgelöst
also insgesamt drei Airbags offen hier
am Kotflügel ist so ein bisschen
eingedellt das kriegt man aber
vermutlich wieder rausgezogen ansonsten
keine größeren Schäden hier am großen
Kotflügel was ein Riesenteil ist was bis
aufs Dach geht also das hier wäre
richtiger pain und hier hinten das ist
jetzt das Paradebeispiel hier ist einmal
alles ganz oben gestartet Heckscheibe
habe ich schon gesagt Spoiler und
Spoiler Aufhängung kostet 10 000 €
weniger teuer aber nicht weniger
schmerzhaft hier unten das ducktail Mega
wichtig für so das Aussehen des
Fahrzeugs und die Wirkung und natürlich
auch für die Performance also das Teil
hier ist wahrscheinlich das Teil was
mich am meisten an dem Auto stört das
kaputt ist weil es so klein ist und das
5000 € kostet halt alles aus Carbon da
drunter Heckleuchte dreiteilig links
rechts und in der Mitte das Band was
durchzieht auch kaputt heckchürze hier
unten das Plastikteil die Auspuffblende
der Diffusor und der Endtopf zum einen
die Endrohre die sind krumm ist aber
nicht weiter schlimm weil der Endtopf
auch einen Hit bekommen hat links und
rechts das geht nicht bis über in cut wo
unsere Abgase schön gefiltert werden die
bleiben auch drin aber der originalpop
bleibt nicht drin also da wenn er jetzt
schon mal kaputt ist kann man ja sich
auch vielleicht ein bisschen neu
orientieren ne insgesamt haben wir nur
eine Felge die den gesamten Aufprall
überlebt hat ohne ersichtliche Schäden
alle anderen drei sind Fritte das geht
auch richtig ins Geld aber
glücklicherweise das wissen wir ja schon
erstmal von den Aufhängungen
Stoßdämpfern und so weiter nichts kaputt
was uns jetzt aber unter dem Wagen
erwartet wissen wir noch nicht wenn
jetzt unten drunter kein größerer
Schaden ist den wir so nicht erwartet
haben dann haben wir die Karre auf dem
Hinterhof während wir den gekauft haben
ohne den vernünftig auf irgendeine
Hebebühne heben zu können komplett
richtig eingeschätzt also das ist jetzt
das Grande Finale indem wir erfahren ob
uns irgendwo einen weiterer 50.000 €
Schaden erwartet oder ein irreparaaber
Schaden oder irgendwas also noch sind
wir nicht durch jetzt ist das große
Finale indem wir erfahren ob das alles
so wieder herzurichten ist wie wir uns
das vorstellen also hier den Kühler hat
dann halt komplett zerrissen und
traurigerweise der Kofferraum woden aber
das wichtigste die Vorderachse also hier
dieses Blech hat nur diesen kleinen
Ecken hier also gar nichts der hat keine
Verformung das Auto wurde vermessen
zuvor in im Gutachten also dann gibt's
unten drunter ein Gerät das stellt man
drunter das hat ein Finger damit kann
man alle tastpunkte anfahren und dann
sieht man hinter dreidimensional ist
alles okay oder weicht da irgendwas ein
halben Millimeter nur ab und das passt
alles das hat uns halt noch mal die
Bestätigung gegeben dass hiermit oder
strukturell oder von der Verformung des
Fahrzeug alles in Ordnung ist das sieht
man auch jetzt so leihenhaft auf den
ersten Blick schaut man unter die Karre
drunter sieht die spitzenmäßig aus sch
das mal an der sieht clean aus also das
der Schaden ging wirklich hier bis dahin
bis da wo es kritisch wird und da Stopp
bis da hinten komplett runter sieht
alles fein aus und kann hier erkennen
das hat einfach nichts abbekommen das
ist das niedrigste von von allen Teilen
hier aus dem ganzen stoßdämpferbereich
und da ist nichts dran also wirklich
nicht mal irgendwie gekratzt da dran
okay kommen jetzt zum Heck des Fahrzeugs
auch wichtig empfindlich und kann
richtig schnell ins Geld gehen weil
Porsche Motor hinten das bedeutet
Einschläge bei Unfällen auf der
Rückseite ist richtig pain und wir
gesehen habt hinten ist alles kaputt
also war beim Kauf erstmal davon
auszugehen dass uns hier auch böse
Überraschungen erwarten und das hat's
auch aber weniger schlimm als gedacht
man kann schon erahnen dass es hier
tiefer gefäh icher Punkt werden kann
also man rennt über ein Bordstein dann
kannst hier unten schnell mal ein
pllaffendes Loch reinschlagen hier kann
man aber sehen das BCH ist fast nicht
berührt also ist nur Dreck und hier ein
bisschen angeschliffen hier der
hinterachs Querträger sieht man jetzt
auch keine Abnutzungsspuren da hat ein
ganz klein bisschen eingedellt aber
jetzt man kann es immer noch fahren also
ist gar kein Problem und hier außen hat
s den Katalysator hier auch leicht
verformt was aber jetzt keinerlei
Funktion insschränkung darstellt sondern
erstmal nur Optik das sieht gut aus hier
auf der Seite sieht's noch besser aus
aber natürlich der cherdämpfer da sieht
man hier da hat es ihn schon gut
zerknickt gleich so auf der anderen
Seite sind auch ein paar böse Spuren
dran aber sonst hier unten drunter das
Herzstück eines jeden ne
elers Gott sei Dank nichts berührt keine
weiteren großen Sachen keine scheiße
also echt
Lucky nice Alter was für ein Relief ihr
müsst euch vorstellen ich habe die Kohle
investiert mit einem guten ersten Blick
darauf durch Robin aber die
Möglichkeiten das Auto anzuschauen sind
super limitiert super limitiert das ist
jetzt das erste Mal dass wir vernünftig
drunter schauen können und alleine auf
den ersten Blick nichts Großes weiteres
zu sehen ist ein riesen Relief für mich
was das im Umkehrschluss bedeutet ist
dass wir genau richtig eingeschätzt
haben was tatsächlich mit dem Auto ist
dass uns an keinem weiteren Träger
irgendwas erwartet hat dass die
Kalkulation die reparaturkalkulation von
180.000 € bei weitem nicht das ist was
wir ausgeben müssen um die Karre wieder
hinzubekommen und das mechanisch an dem
Auto gar nichts kaputt ist obwohl es
eine Sache gibt die bei ein Aufprall und
bei dem Auslösen von airwex passiert für
die wir zum zumindest einen großen Teil
vom Auto komplett auseinandernhmen
müssen dazu aber später mehr das will
ich ja auch noch mal sagen das war
obwohl ich die bestmöglichen Vorkehrung
getroffen hat trotz alledem immer noch
ein Glücksgriff viele Sachen konnten wir
Vorort nicht sehen und mussten uns
darauf verlassen dass es so ist wie wir
es hoffen dass es jetzt am Ende wirklich
so geworden ist ist ein Glücksgriff und
das heißt nicht dass ihr jetzt losrennen
könnt den erstbesten Wagen auf mobile
nehmt und ihr mit einer ähnlichen Sache
rechnen könnt unsere Euphorie nach dem
ersten Blick war unfassbar keine
weiteren schlimmen Schäden bedeutet auch
gut für den Geldbeutel und einfacher die
Karre wieder hinzubekommen und sollte
aber noch eine böse Überraschung
erwarten erstmal hieß es aber das Auto
weiter auseinander
nehmen rathausschalen haben wir gerade
abgenommen bedeutet jetzt können wir die
Frontschürze abnehmen angefangen am
Vorderwagen haben wir innerhalb von
wirklich wenigen Minuten den gesamten
Vorderwagen auseinander genommen
angefangen mit der Verkleidung diger und
jetzt sieht man hier der Kühler hat
natürlich richtig einen abbekommen rüber
zu den klimakühlern dann Wasserkühler
und schlussendlich den Aufpralldämpfer
und leider hat uns hier ein größerer
Schaden erwartet als gedacht oh war ja
wir dachten das Blech hier raust trennen
zu können und quasi nur das hier zu
ersetzen das hier oben ist der
Längsträger da ist gar nichts dran das
ist wunderbar wir dachten aber nur
dieses Teil ersetzen zu können jetzt ist
aber das Problem wir müssen dieses Teil
hier auch ersetzen und hier ist ein Teil
von der doppelaufnahme vom vom Lenker
dran und das ist natürlich doof denn
dieses Teil geht über einen einfachen
Blechschaden hinaus ihr müsst wissen bei
Porsche gibt es Schäden die irreparabel
sind bzw nicht instand gesetzt werden
dürfen wir haben es hier mit einem
Rennwagen zu tun 510 PS der am Ende full
power auf der Rennstrecke am Limit des
Wagens und auch am Limit des Fahrers
bewegt werden soll deswegen hat
Funktionalität und Sicherheit absolute
Priorität auch in unserem Wiederaufbau
das ist number one priority um zu wissen
ob dieser Schaden jetzt genauso ein
Schaden ist ein irreparabler Schaden der
nicht wieder instand gesetzt werden darf
muss das Auto von dem Profi begutachtet
werden von dem Profi der Porsche
zertifiziert ist und uns eine llare
Ansage geben kann ob das Projekt genau
an diesem Punkt endet all das was seine
Einschätzung ist und ob wir den Wagen
wieder reparieren können erfahrt ihr im
nächsten Video also vergesst nicht den
Kanal zu abonnieren das hier könnte
jetzt tatsächlich nach der ganzen
Euphorie das
Ende des Aufbaus bedeuten am Vorderwagen
sind uns also die Hände gebunden
bedeutet wir machen einfach am Heck
weiter als erstes das ducktail runter um
an die Schrauben der Heckleuchten zu
kommen welche wir natürlich auch direkt
abgemacht haben dann heckstoßschange
aufpalldämpfer und den sich zuerst etwas
querstellenden enttopf der
Abgasanlage Bo Alter gefangen Heck ist
mittlerweile auch auseinander gebaut
keine weiteren Schäden entdeckt was
ziemlich gut ist mit einer neuen
Abgasanlage sind wir da schon gut
bedient und m neuen Heck und ein neuen
ducktail und m neuen Diffusor und ein
neuen Spoiler und neuen Aufhängung und
eigentlich allem anderen was außerhalb
des mechanischen Bereichs am Heck liegt
ja aber ist schon geil jetzt innerhalb
von wenigen Stunden die Karre so so
zerlegt hier im hinterwagenbereich zu
sehen und natürlich auch hier vorne
außerdem habe ich gerade ziemlich gute
News bekommen was Karosseriearbeiten für
direkt die nächsten Tage angeht es gibt
jemanden der sich des Themas für uns
annimmt und der wird uns sagen können ob
das ein reparabler Schaden ist oder ob
ich hier gerade mein gesamtes Erspartes
versenkt habe zumindest haben wir aber
jemanden gefunden der Porsche
zertifiziert wieder aufbauen kann wenn
es denn möglich ist und das ist richtig
gut das bedeutet
dass ich mich um alle mechanischen um
alle Sachen wie Frontstoßstange und so
weiter mit Robin kümmer der bei Porsche
gelernt hat der weiß wie das alles geht
und sich jemand beim Karosserie Thea
auch darum kümmert der auch Plan hat und
der auch Porsche zertifiziert ist das
bedeutet das ist ja keine
hinterhofaktion also es ist eine
hinterhofaktion aber keine
hinterhofaktion wo ich mir irgendeinen
zusammenbastel sondern die Karre steht
wenn wir es schaffen wenn die Teile hier
im Karosseriebereich austauschbar sind
am Ende wieder wie neu da ein kleiner
Blick ins Herzstück hier sitzt der 4 l
Flat six drunter gibt uns die Leistung
die wir brauchen das kümmern wir uns
jetzt darum ihr seht es die fahrradtür
ist komplett gesmasht die rauszubauen
und nicht nur auszubauen sondern die
neue tatsächlich direkt einzusetzen
glücklicherweise und das wird jeder
wissen der schon mal irgendwas mit dem
Karosseriebauer zu tun hatte
Karosseriebauer ist gleichzeitig auch
Lackierer bedeutet wenn wir die Karre
jetzt fertig machen um sie abzugeben ist
natürlich mega geil dass wir die
grundierte Tür schon mit eingeben die
einmal eingepasst haben gucken ob das
alles funktioniert und die dann direkt
mitgelackt werden kann jetzt erstmal Tür
ab neue Tür rein Sitz raus und anfangen
den Innenraum auseinander zu nehmen weil
da muss durch die ausgelösten Airbags
auch eine Menge Menge Zeug gemacht
werden es kommt noch eine Menge also
hieß es die Tür in eingehängtem Zustand
komplett auseinander zu nehmen und vor
allem die gerissene Scheibe zufäht die
können wir natürlich nicht wieder
verwenden aber die ganzen Innenteile
also die komplette Türverkleidung den
Knopf für das hoch und runter fahren der
Scheibe den Griff und die gesamte
Mechanik wie auch das Schloss kommen
natürlich in unsere neue Tür mit der
abgeschraubten Tür hatten wir jetzt
genug Platz um den Innenraum
vorzubereiten vorzubereiten heißt in
unserem Fall den Innenraum komplett
auseinander zuhmen und genau darum hat
sich Robin gekümmert währenddessen
konnte ich den Kofferraum welcher im 91
immer vorne im Wagen sitzt von seiner
Verkleidung
befreien clubsportpaket wird ausgebaut
also Überrollkäfig kommt raus Sitz ist
schon
draußen
perf niceness
[Musik]
Platz da drin ist Alter soll ich aus dem
GT3 ein Campingmobil bauen Beifahrersitz
raus und dann Liegefläche rein kann mal
schauen was nächste alles noch mit
diesem GT3 passiert letzte Sache die es
für uns jetzt so richtig zu tun gibt ist
die neue Tür einzusetzen die einmal
einzupassen schon mal so dass wir den
Wagen mit der neuen Tür transportieren
und der so beim Karosseriebauer
[Musik]
ankommt
noch fein einstellen D die n dran
kommt neue Tür drin Sache von 2 Minuten
natürlich das hier passt jetzt alles
noch nicht 100% aber darum geht's auch
nicht geht jetzt darum die Tür einmal
drin zu haben die so grob zu fitten und
das Auto damit dann wegfahren zu können
jetzt kommt noch das Türschloss rein
dass die man zumindest einrasten kann
sonst bauen mit die Tür darum wä auch
nicht gut und ja rein damit am Ende muss
die Karre rollbar sein damit wir sie
easy von A nach B bekommen können
deswegen abendshandlung für uns an
diesem Tag vorabtransport war die Räder
wieder dran zu bekommen letzte
abendshandlung beim letzten Mal haben
wir es von draußen gefilmt diesmal von
drin müssen die Centerlock wheels wieder
festballern mit richtig Druck bedeutet
ich muss auf dem Fahrersitz und die
Bremse komplett durchtreten Problem wir
haben keinen Sitz Schau wir mal wie das
möglich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ist
oh Mann und dann hieß es Abfahrt
Richtung Karosseriebauer so Auto für
zwei Tage hier in der Halle gewesen
alles gemacht was ging und da ist der
LKW und das Auto jetzt am Sonntagabend
wieder absolen damit wir morgen mit den
Karosseriearbeiten weitermachen können
200 km Richtung Köln Abfahrt in Kolonne
mit unserem Abschleppdienst ging es also
auf eine Reise 200 km von unserer
Werkstatt zum
Karosseriebau ja ihr müsst euch das
vorstellen vor 8 Tagen habe ich die
Karre das erste Mal gesehen jetzt ist
die weitestgehend auseinander gebaut und
steht fertig beim Porsche zertifizierten
Karosseriebauer besser geht's nicht
Alter ich schwöre so schnell wurde noch
nie ein 992 GT3 wieder aufgebaut
geschweige denn irgendeine Karre wir
ballern das hier so krank durch und
alles funktioniert auf den letzten
Millimeter genau es ist Sonntag abend 21
Uhr der Chef von Teegarten Karosserie
macht mir hier die Bude auf hilft beim
Schieben also schon ein dickes shoutout
an Teegarten Karosserie die sich dem
Thema hier so kurzfristig annehmen was
für ein Traum besser geht's nicht ob es
jetzt tatsächlich so Traum auf weiter
geht wie hier gerade beschrieben erfahrt
im nächsten Video also vergesst nicht
den Kanal zu abonnieren save
runterzuladen Creator Code Dave
einzutragen und beim onlinees shopen
bares Geld sparen wir sehen uns nächste
Woche zur dritten Folge des günstigsten
992 gt3s wieder macht's gut
ciao